[Música]
y es momento de hablar con nuestra
segunda primera invitada del día y vamos
a hablar de las relaciones entre la
Unión Europea y América Latina porque
reforzarlas ha sido el objetivo de la
presidenta de la comisión europea Úrsula
bonder Legend que esta semana ha estado
en Brasil en Argentina en chile y hoy
visita México y entre otras cuestiones
la jefa del eco ejecutivo europeo
anunció que Bruselas invertirá 10.000
millones de euros en proyectos en
América Latina a través del mecanismo
global Great ahora para analizar Los
lazos entre ambas regiones se conectamos
con la analista internacional doctora
beata oína
beata Muchísimas gracias por estar con
nosotras aquí en France 24 en directo
América Le agradezco mucho su presencia
y le pregunto por qué quiere Bruselas
acercarse ahora a América Latina En qué
medida influye en este acercamiento la
guerra en Ucrania la necesidad de
materias primeras para la transición
energética o la influencia que gana
china en la región
buenos días Rosa un gusto saludarte a ti
a la audiencia efectivamente en esos
días la presidenta de la comisión
europea está de viaje en América Latina
hoy va a visitar México por la tarde va
a tener reunión con el presidente
mexicano López Obrador la razón es son
los que las que tú mencionas sin ninguna
duda Pero no cabe No cabe duda también
que en un mes se va a celebrar la Cumbre
entre Unión Europea América Latina y el
Caribe y el objetivo de la presidenta de
la comisión Úrsula fonder Legend es
garantizar la participación de los
cuatro países Argentina chile Brasil y
México en esta Cumbre a nivel más alto
de hecho los tres de Argentina de Brasil
y de Chile ya han confirmado que
participarán en cuanto al presidente
mexicano la verdad es que dudo que lo
haga porque está ahora ya en proceso
electoral y normalmente él no suele
viajar al extranjero entonces garantizar
esa participación Por una parte y por
otra parte garantizar los resultados
quiere decir anuncios sobre los acuerdos
de modernización de los
que tiene firmados la Unión Europea con
chile por ejemplo Unión Europea con
México y en caso de mercosur pues está
pendiente por ahí un acuerdo muy
importante también para para
ratificación entonces en este contexto
garantizar eso Por una parte Por otra
parte también hay que tener en
consideración que la Unión Europea y
América Latina y Caribe no se reunieron
en ese tipo de Cumbre desde hace ocho
años entonces sí es es un punto
relevante en este en este contexto y
finalmente tomar en consideración que a
raíz de la guerra de Rusia contra
Ucrania se han manifestado con mucha
fuerza las diferencias de carácter
político que existen entre la Unión
Europea y los países de la región y en
ese sentido pues la Cumbre sirve para
retomar esa relación que es una relación
basada en lazos sólidos sin ninguna duda
desde el punto de vista institucional
desde el punto de vista del número de
acuerdos que existen entre América
Latina y
El Caribe y la Unión Europea pero una
relación que yo diría Y eso eso en eso
coinciden muchos incluso algunos
funcionarios de de la Unión Europea ha
sido una relación de alguna forma
abandonada en los últimos años por
varias razones entre ellas precisamente
beata porque la quiere recuperar ahora
esta relación Más allá de esta Cumbre
que viene que temas quiere abordar la
Unión Europea en esta Cumbre porque le
interesan estos tratados de libre
comercio con mercosur con chile con
México que puede conseguir cada uno de
los bloques en este acercamiento
aquí obviamente hay varios elementos
varias razones a tomar en consideración
en primer lugar yo diría es ahí la razón
política los países de América Latina y
del Caribe en total hablamos de un
bloque de 33 países que tienen un peso
significativo en el contexto de los de
los foros multilaterales como las
Naciones Unidas asamblea general
obviamente y a raíz de la guerra se
detectó que no todos los países quizás
tienen la misma percepción por ejemplo
de la guerra de Rusia contra Ucrania No
necesariamente quieren este compartir
con la Unión Europea la misma
perspectiva sobre la guerra y sobre las
relaciones internacionales entonces en
primer lugar fortalecer esas relaciones
entre entre las regiones Estableciendo
un mecanismo que permitiera pues cierta
institucionalización y regularidad En
las reuniones políticas entre Unión
Europea y la región Por otra parte es
muy relevante también el aspecto
económico efectivamente a raíz de las
transformaciones que observamos por la
invasión rusa a Ucrania pues la Unión
Europea está buscando también
proveedores seguros proveedores
amistosos de materias primas relevantes
como el caso de litio Y eso coincide
También con otra gran Revolución que
estamos viviendo que es la transición
obviamente energética la tradición verde
y a raíz de Esta visita hemos visto que
la Unión Europea a través de Úrsula
fonderlayen firmó un memorando de
cooperación por ejemplo en tema de litio
con este con argentina se está hablando
también a raíz de Esta visita en Chile
sobre el mismo tipo de memorándum de
cooperación en el caso de chile entonces
hay ese interés económico sin ninguna
duda también y ofertas también de
cooperación económica y fíjate y en que
puede beneficiar América Latina este
acercamiento con la Unión Europea Más
allá de exportar materias primeras
Mira es importante lo que estás
preguntando porque muchas veces se ve a
la Unión Europea como una parte que
extrae pero que no aporta en ese sentido
las propuestas que ha hecho Úrsula
fonderlay en relación con Lito litio
están relacionadas con obviamente
desarrollar toda una cadena de
producción relacionada con este mineral
parte de eso este están proponiendo una
inversión de 10 mil millones de euros en
diferentes proyectos relacionados sobre
todo con temas de energía verde la
transición verde se han firmado un par
de acuerdos sobre hidrógeno con chile
con con Argentina y con Brasil también y
finalmente transición digital que es
también un tema muy relevante tanto para
la Unión Europea como como América
Latina de hecho ya existe una alianza
digital entre las dos partes y pues el
dinero que del que está hablando úsula
fondan Diez mil millones de euros Pues
están precisamente para para ese tipo de
proyectos de hecho ya hay un compromiso
de casi dos mil y medio millones de de
euros en el contexto de Brasil con mucha
Claridad
esa propuesta ha sido expresada por por
Úrsula de Legends Lamentablemente se nos
acaba el tiempo para abordar esta
cuestión seguro que la trataremos con
más tiempo más adelante Muchísimas
gracias por estar con nosotros en 24
Muchas gracias y buen día y ustedes
Recuerden que hacemos una pequeña pausa
pero enseguida volvemos
[Música]